hey guys merry here and I'm going to do
something I don't normally do on
gamespot but I thought I'd give it a try
I played a game yesterday called Feist
and I wanted to just quickly talk about
it if you like this video I can try to
do these a little bit more often or if
you hate it let me know and I'll just
never do it again so anyway I saw a few
screenshots of this game yesterday and
it caught my eye you can tell right away
it's got a pretty unique look to it this
is Feist it's a 2d platformer and it's
got dynamic enemies and a few physics
puzzles thrown in there you could
probably compare it to limbo visually
because it's got this silhouette style
but it takes place in a forest and
because of that there's a lot more
detail in the trees and the grass and
all the horrible gross forest creatures
that are trying to kill you it's
gorgeous and that's super misleading
because game is really really upsetting
everything in the game is trying to kill
you it's not really the large creatures
these gross creepy spider things and
then there's even like traps in the
ground that throw spikes at you so like
you're going to die in this game and to
make it worse you're like this endearing
little soot sprite in this giant
carnivorous world and you're just a
hundred percent gonna die and that's
also kind of comparable to limbo right
like you're going to find things out by
dying and then you learn oh right there
spikes down there or oh okay if i touch
this tripwire a bunch of spikes rain
from the ceiling and kill me so you can
avoid these traps too just like jumping
over them or you could set them off and
run away real quickly but you can also
use them to your advantage and they'll
help you kill some of the stuff that's
trying to kill you but in many
situations I found myself just running
as fast as I could do the level not
killing anything because it's way easier
if you just run away and
I felt like I was had a better chance of
living the game puts you in these really
intense situations and you feel like
you're just a hundred percent hopeless
and helpless and most the time I felt
like that was a good thing because
everything is dynamic it felt like maybe
I just had bad luck that time I should
have jumped a little higher and you
wouldn't have caught me and smashed me
onto the ground or I could have it could
have thrown the brick a different way
which would have helped me out later on
in the level so you learn little things
but even if your play is perfect they're
just times when you know it sucks and
you die and that's the way it is it was
a good feeling to me that it's not
always just my fault sometimes the world
just says you're you're gonna die in
this scenario you're caught and and
you're done for it made me feel like the
world was against me and it was up to me
to play well and also utilize everything
that I could to survive some of the
enemies like this weird Hedgehog monster
and they change based on what you do so
if I jump a little higher he might turn
around and grab me right out of the air
but if I run away he will chase me and
these guys are actually faster than you
so you can't just run away from them
they will catch you and typically they
end up picking me up and throwing me
against these rocks and you just feel
super helpless so you eventually have to
turn around and hit them with something
and it won't even actually stop them
most of the time they just like batted
away and keep trying to destroy you but
if you keep at it you know you really
can feel like you can actually
accomplish something and this tiny
little guy that you are I can actually
do something in the world it's brutal
and it's heartbreaking but it's
incredibly engrossing and the game is a
little short I burned through it in like
an hour so it's not very long and
because it's got puzzles in it I don't
know about the replay value because you
know some people might enjoy replaying
it and trying to beat it quicker or
something but that's not really my style
I probably won't you replay it
and I was hoping the environments would
change more as well I always felt like I
was in the same area you're typically
either in the forest or this underground
cavern area but they look very similar
so I never really felt a huge amount of
progression overall though I felt like
the art and the music and the gameplay
did a really good job of putting me in
this frightening world and making me
root for this little fuzzball creature
and and I just really wanted to survive
and that pretty much sums up most of my
thoughts you can get it on steam for
fifteen dollars but I bet it'll go on
sale at some point if that feels a
little high I hope you guys liked this
style of video and let me know your
thoughts thanks for watching bye